i did not in any way shape or form style
my hair to do this
it just did it and i look like a 70s
housewife and that's okay today we are
catching up on the indie world showcase
uh for nintendo switch i always love
seeing these because there are loads of
games that i don't know anything about
which is always very exciting usually a
lot of very different visual styles a
lot of different kinds of games just a
cool idea of an upcoming calendar
because you also often get release dates
so they're always very creative and fun
so let's watch it shall we this is the 5
11 2022
indie world showcase
there's always a good time
judakova 19 release dates and other
information presented in this video
subjects changed that's not code but
specific release dates are always
subject to change
that's not some new thing
appreciate you
saying it though
hello and welcome to indie world i'm a
rico and i'm amber we're back today to
showcase a slew of indie games coming to
the nintendo switch system our indie
partners span the globe from sweden to
australia and japan that's me and we
can't wait to see what they've been
cooking up
so let's get started
cool
booblets
i do know this game blitz is
so cute and quite fun i enjoyed
i believe there's ublet's gameplay on
this channel if you want to check it out
[Music]
i also
did a dj set that was only four guys in
erblitz songs
it was hard
[Music]
damn
i never got through all this
that's a lot of content
[Music]
don't you just love games that are cozy
and weird oh i absolutely do
this charming creature collection and
farm simulation game from glen berlin
this is some bad acting
but i get it they're reading the script
row and train are told to be open
creatures
as you cultivate new life i'm also a bad
actor i get it
customize your character
befriend the locals
decorate your house
run your own shop
i know you could do that i should have
played more riblets have epic dance
battles
you can even dress up your ooblet pals
and travel to different locations
visit the arcade-packed boardwalk and
port forward
sauntered through the spooky swamps of
nowhere and i don't know if they added
more content frozen peaks
waddles its way onto nintendo's switch
this summer i'm sure a lot of people
enjoy it
colorful and mesmerizing planets awaits
in this fast-paced action rpg across the
cosmos
in this deeply story-driven game by
storm mind games you'll use both
strength and wits to interact with
others i don't think i've heard of this
for the challenges it might already be
out there balancing the duality of your
physical
and mental powers is key
sacrifice one for the other against
opponents and
things might not turn out well for you
ultimately your conscience will carry
the weight of your decisions
it's reminding me of hades even though i
imagine has nothing to complain
[Music]
so
[Music]
puzzle platforming
[Music]
i see what you did there
[Music]
that's neat this is cool
cool design
we've seen a million games that look
like this right
that's your marios video games that look
like this have been around for a very
long time but i think these puzzle
mechanics are
very unique which can't be easy
[Music]
that's very cool super creative hey
if you're looking for a clever and
challenging 2d puzzle platformer then
we've got just the game for you from
nama takahashi a one-person development
team
here you're so impressed who's on a
mission to restore light to the world
while navigating a booby-trapped
facility
by using your electrifying power try
this touch walls floors platforms and
switches
electricity will charge through them and
bring them to life
hey and i'm very bad at platforming so
yourself
i mean actually you see how it goes
detach and throw your head to trigger
objects you'll need to retrieve it
within 10 seconds or else i wonder if oh
i wonder if you get
in rooms new abilities to discover
so use your head
literally
shut up every nook and cranny of the
facility
elect head bolts onto nintendo switch
this summer
that's cool
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm loving all these rhythm games we
keep getting lately
like there have been this like increase
in rhythm fps's
i think it's super cool
[Music]
i feel i feel represented
i just need slightly pink ahead feel the
beat and sound fall this fast-paced
rhythm-based dungeon crawler from noodle
cake and jurassic games combines little
shooter action with musical gameplay
that'll keep you on your toes maybe i
still think i'm tapping your toes as a
guardian of harmony you're transported
to the world of symphonia to battle the
forces of discord
move to the music solo or with up to
four players locally or online as you
restore harmony to symphonia's
corruption i'm curious about this for
sure levels and encounters are
dynamically generated from the music and
there are over a hundred and forty songs
to choose from so pick the to be a fun
stream game like a stream multiplayer
games
and your power will increase bonuses
there are five different musical heroes
to choose from
over 500 pieces of equipment for skill
customization and thousands
get your head boppin to soundfall
launching on the nintendo switch system
later today i think i hate the vo it's
not their fault
why is it freezing in here i think it's
more of a direction
i think i hate it and wild frost but i
get it take on these
job to do in this tactical roguelike
deck builder from deadpan games
build and customize your deck as you set
off to put an end to the eternal frost
card companions and items are at your
disposal
use them to battle wave after wave of
monsters
i like the odd style it's hard to get me
into a new deck builder because i'm so
happy with the ones i already play
by the way everybody smooth using the
dynamic counter system in case i haven't
mentioned that
frosty after each run try daily
challenges or expand the hub town of
snow dwell to unlock new events and
cards
helpful for your fight against the
perpetual winter
wild frost makes its snowy debut on
nintendo switch this holiday
is rebecca we're from landfall games a
small game studio based in stockholm
sweden and we are excited to announce
that our game totally accurate battle
simulator or tabs for short will be
coming to nintendo switch cool we first
started working on super fun 2016. the
idea was to make a game that is inspired
by the feeling you got when it is your
action figures as a kid we then added
the strategy and fighting elements and
turned the game into the wobbly
experience that it is today our
wonderful community has been with us
along the way and helped us shape the
game with our suggestions and feedback
so together with them we're proud to
bring tabs to this awesome platform
it suits the switch super well like the
only
thing i've had against tabs
is that i have trouble sitting at a pc
and playing it for a long period of time
because it feels so silly or i'm like
but i could be playing
this meaty rpg or whatever whereas
playing
totally accurate battle simulator on a
plane or something
it suits the switch for sure
and as is the curse of the switch i just
keep buying games
i don't know how many times i've done it
it's a real switch problem
[Music]
wait what
you heard that right in this fighting
game from landfall games you'll lead
teams of over one call it a fighting
game
but i don't know what else i'd call it
from ancient lands
spooky worlds and fantasy realms those
wobbly physics are
very uh wobbly oh they're awesome and
those aren't your garden variety battles
either watch your wobblers flail and
fail in silly simulated battles or make
new ones
[Music]
it's not trying to be a movie or a tv
show it's just trying to be a video game
and it sure is above
the wobble send them definitely like
take some of the silliness that's
inherent in game development and
capitalizes on it in a way that's really
small
you never cease to amaze me
totally accurate battle simulator
wobbles it's way onto nintendo switch
this summer it's killing me
he's killing me
[Music]
action adventure huh
[Music]
i'm into this
[Music]
i didn't expect that yeah mary poppins
this looks cool
they had me at everything and then they
called it jumbrella
town to a junkyard for this is what art
is use the gumbrella to glide swing
dash dive and take out enemies this is
the best thing we've ever really
side-scrolling combat
along the way
you'll scavenge for scraps and spare
parts to upgrade the umbrella
and employ your sleep
you know sometimes you just go for it
it's our characters
rapidly losing its natural resources
and that's just the beginning of your
investigation
plenty of dark twists and turns lie
ahead
very into this tonality launches on
nintendo switch next year yes please
thank you devolver
banging everyone i'm jared huntley lead
programmer on we are ofk and i'm luca
lafaye lead singer of the band ofk
we're super excited to announce that our
music biopic game is coming to nintendo
switch yes ooh i can play it on a tour
bus oh i can't wait to tour together we
haven't seen each other since that music
video brainstorm at your place in la in
2019 yeah wow wow and with the game on
handheld it'll be easy to play the new
episodes that are coming out every day
this is a game i don't think i've heard
of that i guess is already i can't wait
to share ofk's story and music with
y'all
hey jared can i get your opinion on tour
outfits
sounds like it's already out
[Music]
okay mom
bam
okay who is she
[Music]
everybody's hot
did the gays make this
the gays make games where everyone's hot
and i'm very appreciative
they just keep doing it
[Music]
it's so good
[Music]
don't have an idea of what it is can we
get some gameplay this musical narrative
from indie pop band ofk is from the band
itself
emotional ride
set in downtown los angeles it sumi
saito struggles to establish herself in
la's ruthless music scene while managing
a full-time job
a social life and a brutal commute
but a chance encounter with a rising
hollywood music producer making of the
band series and interactive ep
how creative episodes released weekly
and interactive music videos with the
fully voiced cast interesting to witness
the lives of itsumi and her friends
unfold um
thank you
from fighting over sound lyrics at band
practice to sending silly memes via text
it's a heartfelt making of the band
journey that's sure to pull at your
heartstrings
we are ofk drums onto nintendo switch
this summer
generally not my kind of game gameplay
wise but it looks very cute and i'm tom
and everybody spiral circus we are an
indie games developer based in bristol
uk
and our passion for the stranger and
surreal side of art is what brought us
together we've both come from really
different backgrounds
i was a research scientist and tom is a
fine artist because of the pandemic
we've been an entirely remote team and
almost all of silt has been hand drawn
at night by me which seems entirely
appropriate for the subject matter our
audio designer even set up a fish tank
in a studio to record the underwater
sounds that you'll be hearing throughout
the game that's cool we're really
excited
so no hand-drawn work brought to life
and we hope you enjoy exploring the
strange oceanic world of silt i think
i've heard
take a deep breath and dive into the
harrowing ocean abyss damn in the depths
of this puzzle adventure from spiral
circus games a little bit inside
long forgotten mysteries as you explore
a surreal underwater realm filled with
strange machinery ancient ruins and
dangerous ocean inhabitants
i will almost definitely a variety of
sea creatures can be possessed
harness their abilities to solve puzzles
cool the haunting environment
and surviving counters against deep sea
goliaths fly in here there's more than
meets the eye in this unsettling
monochrome world
plunge into the dark water very pretty
yeah i'll probably play that one
nintendo switch
next time that is my
style it's like a
generally a short up
to avoid traffic
morning commutes can be a real jam
if you get my drift
oh i know right
is this an extension of that motorways
from developer dinosaur polo that
original like ipad to solving the city's
traffic connection problems is you
draw and build roads to create can
somebody come do that in l.a
and keep traffic flowing on maps
inspired by real life city because jesus
christ as demands interchange you'll
continuously redesign and expand via
upgrades like highways and roundabouts
ramp up the difficulty by taking part in
daily and weekly challenges
more maps will unlock as you become a
master road designer
how long can you keep the cities of the
world moving
buckle up for mini motorways cruising
onto nintendo switch later today oh cool
it's the the releases are neat the
amount of later today's they have
perspective that's new i've never seen
that before
then hop aboard this heartfelt narrative
adventure from ghost pattern set in
1970s rural australia
as intrepid teen journalist casey you'll
come to know a diverse cast of eclectic
voiced characters through the stories
they tell and the moments
each story unfolds in real time at the
same time so you get to choose which
ones you want to expect cool like sleep
no more follow the hospitals that's very
cool eavesdrop on them or enter the room
and be part of the conversation
darcy right mrs b's kid he's actually
australian it's um casey
not i'm casey just casey
sure
by keeping track you're both australian
in your notebook
that's cool everything playing out
regardless of what you do is
new stories locations and revelations
multiple playthroughs will also give you
the opportunity to witness other events
allowing you to delve deeper into the
story i'll do this one i'll play this
for sure for the australian but also for
the creativity that's wayward strand
lands on nintendo switch july 21st it's
actually made by
an aussie studio it was randomly
generated world awaits in this
action-adventure game for massive
monster
as a possessed lamb saved by a
foreboding stranger from a ritual
sacrifice
you need to repay your debt this looks
cool too creating a loyal community of
woodland worshipers
gather resources to build structures
based in melbourne nice to meet you
gather your courage to brave deadly
dungeons like this looks different
venture through its dark depths teeming
with razor spiders and toxic millipedes
to challenge the dungeons overlord
shimura
there ain't anything sheepish about it
cult of the lamb trots on to nintendo
switch this year
a lot of this year's nondescript this
year
oh hello huh tiny friend
oh my gosh
who's this young man
it sounds like
what
come on now
oh my god
[Music]
i have a massive phobia of crabs i feel
like that's gonna be a problem for me
here
they're like
number two on the list of things i'm
afraid of
wow that looks very cool and i won't be
able to play it because i'll be too
scared of all the crabs
hey crab fans i'm nick and i'm kalyn
previously aggro crab released going
under and it didn't make us rich so this
time we were selling out i'm giving the
people what they want crabs our second
project is a crustacean themed souls
another crabs treasure through our
extensive research we've found that
crabs are the perfect enemy for an
action game they've got natural weapons
can strafe from side to side and you can
hit their weak point for massive damage
souls likes are known for their
difficulty and we want to create a game
that maintains that challenge while
being approachable for new fans of the
genre what if you died in one hit when
you're not wearing a shell i just said
it's supposed to be approachable oh what
if every time you dodge roll there's
like a one percent chance that you just
trip and follow well it looks like our
segment's over everyone
it's time for crab
they're very charming and that makes me
appreciate it more
oh here we go
this is so cute
absolutely
anyway
in this action adventure from aggro i
can't play it you'll embark on a
treasure hunt under the sea he's not
going to happen to
oh no i literally am covered in chills
and it's just cute
maybe this is what uh helps me get over
my phobia to defend yourself in
challenging combat
there are over 50 potential shells so
get shelter it's a great idea enemies
with powerful umami magic
if you don't you'll be in a pinch before
you know it
it's not going to happen to me
the game looks awesome please play it on
my behalf
we'd like to show you oh man
that's right
coming to nintendo's switch enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
it got too fast my head hurts
[Music]
pretty
[Music]
very pretty
ori vibes
[Music]
excited about cod chalk
sounds very interesting
[Music]
a lot of creative golf games out there
good huh that's cool
[Music]
a guidebook of fable
[Music]
couldn't even register what that is
gameplay-wise
[Music]
available later today so many of those
that's so cool
that looks cool too
that's all for today's india well thanks
we hope you enjoyed the slew of games in
today's showcase
a big thank you to our indie community
and andy partners working on games for
nintendo's switch and as always thank
you for watching
check out our official twitter account
to stay up to date on all the latest
indie world news
until next time
happy gaming thanks friends
um
so not like a ton of stuff for me there
but i feel like that's always the case
with those actually with nintendo
directs in general um though i guess
this isn't a nintendo direct they call
it a new world showcase that no matter
what though they're always so fast-paced
and everything is interesting there's so
many interesting things to look at i
feel like you rarely see something
that's not like oh interesting i see
what they did there but yeah there are a
couple of things that i was super
interested in um or that i will play uh
probably like three of them i think that
that really stood out to me so
always fun to watch though regardless
even if that vo
a little bit too cheesy for me
you did your best
i get it